you are so right you are so right
because before i lived here the glass
was always covered in smudges oh and i
moved in and i cleaned it so i guess
that makes me the devil
you are she is she is the devil i'm in
hell
you shouldn't joke about that we'd like
to enter into the record of page from
michael scott's personal journal whoa
whoa whoa whoa what are you doing with
my diary this is plaintiff's exhibit
107.
i quote from an entry dated january 4 of
this past year
just got back from jamaica
tan almost everywhere jan almost
everywhere he he
oh diary what a week i had sex with my
boss
i don't know if it's going to go
anywhere jan was very specific that this
is not going anywhere that it was a
one-time mistake but we had sex six
times so you tell me
i am definitely feeling very eerie
iri
irie sorry more tomorrow xoxo michael
it would appear that neither you nor ms
levinson considered you had a
relationship in any sense of the word is
that correct we're going to need to see
a copy of that entire journal before we
produce i don't think anyone in this
room has a right to read my diary it's
basic discovery we have the right to
review it okay let's make ten copies of
this diary um
could you make it eleven
eleven
sure
and we'll break for lunch so everyone
can have a look
how could you give up my diary like that
i had to i'm sorry but i need to win
this we need to win this how'd you even
find it
you keep it under my side of the
mattress i don't like lump i'm really
upset about this all right i stole your
diary and gave it to my lawyer you
emailed a topless photo of me to
everyone in our company let's call it
even fine i love you i love you too
wow i'm so happy i am so deliriously
happy
why because you're pregnant and because
it obviously happened when we were
together and
i am very yeah i did proud when we were
together that's true um but
[Music]
you are not
uh you're not the guy
[Music]
cheated on me
when i specifically asked you not to no
i did not
i did not cheat on you
i did not
walk
okay so it's not mine and it's not
somebody else's so
i know
the whole toilet seat thing is a myth so
i went to
a sperm bank
you did yeah
when we were going out
oh yeah
i don't understand if i was 22 and i had
lots of time to have lots of children
then sure let's let michael have a shot
at one of them but honestly i need to
make this one count
so this is the master bedroom and uh
these walls they used to be like white
like an asylum so i wanted it to be
softer so i had it painted in eggshell
white guess what
white and eggshell white are exactly the
same color
exactly i thought you said that you were
going to tidy things up well
i shave on you
what a cute bench thanks that's my bed
jan has uh some space issues so i curl
up on that puppy
really cause
seems pretty narrow
and short it's actually a lot bigger
than it seems look at this
see
he fits perfectly
hey jan it's so great to see you where's
wallace
what i was under the impression david
wallace would be coming he bought back
dunder mifflin correct hey
your daughter could be a bubble bath
model
i could just bite her head off
sorry um
david is in vermont did you speak with
him he sent dwight instead molly
david wallace is in vermont
oh my god um i talked to his assistant
and i guess it did get a little
confusing because you said not to tell
anyone your name
and then also these bluetooths are very
hard to hear with i know you love the
way they look but tom never had us use
i am not tom i am jan
i'm so sorry jim
anyway
i thought it would be
fun
let's have a little chat with uh david
wallace after all these years
oh will
what are you doing
listening
stop sorry stop that okay
so this was all just a trick you don't
really have any business to give
no i
i do but not to us
insightful pam
oh
oh she's catching up on my sleep
imagine
where's astrid oh i think she's on a
sales call
on a what
more paper
no she's just a coffee break that's
funny
she's with angela
okay
oh you know what there is uh there is
one more thing that you can do for me
okay
don't date holly
that's i hate her
why god
why would you even ask me to
i i mean not that it matters because i
don't but
okay
all right
fine
thanks for the baby shower it's great
and i'll see you soon all right okay
all right
there we go
oh
okay that's nice everybody enjoying
their meal
hey babe yeah how about we take the beer
sign down until our guests leave and
then we can discuss it no no
i'm gonna leave it up i think it ties
the whole room together
okay
[Music]
jan thinks hunter is very talented
you know what
i don't think he's that good at least
he's an artist vfd i'm a screenwriter
and i'm a candlemaker but you don't hear
me bragging about it no all you do is
you get me to try to work on my rich
friends for an investment opportunity
now i would love to burn your candles
you burn it you buy it oh good i'll be
your first customer you're hardly my
first season
[Music]
that is a 200 plus your screen tv you
just killed good luck
paying me back on your zero dollars a
year salary plus benefits babe
you